what I want you to do is now think back
to the trigonometric expansions that you
looked at earlier this year as extension
one students okay the basic tree nitric
suspensions are sign a plus B and cause
a plus B okay do you remember what each
of them is equal to let's start with the
same what's the walk toward you recite
from memory for that okay you go sign a
Cosby plus cause a sign me just for
reasons that are not really been just
fancy I like to put in alphabetical
order whatever it's a plus so it doesn't
pop color saini plus sign be okay so you
should remember that by now this is on
the reference sheet but the reference
sheet is not intended for students like
you should be able to command it very
quickly as extension while students
cause a poor speed what's different
there's two things that are different
okay so instead of mixing up the ratios
right you have them together so cause a
Cosby and then what's the other
difference the sign is backwards okay so
there's our two basic expansions and
obviously here at an air plus B from
each by dividing and off you go now from
here after 10 as well the next place
that this goes to is what if those
angles were the same what if wasn't a
and B but say theta and theta sine 2
theta up for instance so from that
result over there right we say well if
all these angles are the same this is
because theta sine theta this is because
theta sine theta so therefore this is 2
sine theta coz there that is the way it
is to get rid of and do the same for
cause when you do double angle here cos
theta cos theta that's cost web site
they decided okay so you get the idea
okay one of them now that's as far as
you need to really remember I mean again
you can extend these results to tan x
divided through that's all you really
need to remember for purposes of tuna
and extension one but once upon a time
these double angle identities were also
a company in the syllabus by the triple
angle identities okay so we're not going
to do both with them at least not yet
well let's just think about this guy
right let's just think about sign three
theater okay all the building box we
need to work out what sign three things
should be I here on the board right do
you see because i can write down safely
three are sign three venus say that ten
times fast SI 2 theta plus theta do you
agree with that so now 2 theta and theta
are my a in maybe does that make sense
okay so i should be able to sort of work
this out using these other tools that I
know can you spend a couple of minutes
to sort of get as far as you can its
advanced I'll give you a bit of a head
start and then I'll show you what I've
got okay um your most of the way there
it's fine if you're not finished you can
see I have skipped some lines here
because there are really two important
spots as you go through and do your
substitutions from here that are
important here's the first important
stop okay when you go ahead and you
expand so I would write I expect your
next line after this will be something
like close to theater sine theta Society
2 theta cos theta yeah and then you just
use these guys you substitute them in
and you notice you'll have some signs
and cosines that multiplied together so
you get something like this now this is
true and you sort of you brought down to
the sort of fundamental mode when you
expand out everything you can and this
is fine it's true it is not the way
usually then it is written though
because you can sort of push it a bit
further you start up with sign right so
this sign is something nice about
turning something in signs
into something else with site now you
have a lot of signs here and then you
have this guy hanging around what could
we do with this one what could your
placement session 1 minus side spread
video you can use the Pythagorean
identity right that will place
everything with side is which is kind of
nice right once you expand it I believe
you'll get you get for we get three
first tier three rings cool
okay so I think let me check yeah it
looks good this is where we end okay now
this is fine and this is correct and
it's kind of nice okay however this
between you and me I have a side three
theater right I don't really want to
hang around for save for theta or insane
5 theta um you know you maybe you looked
at that yo yo what happened to that like
me my signs are backwards that's because
sienten go oh that's because there's
just so much working it's easy to get
confused and the longer this goes it's
just going to become you know
opportunities for manual error so is
there another way is there something
that we've been looking out recently
where we see trig identities or trig
functions rather with multiples of
angles in them and the answer is to
Morris there right we've been working in
the complex number world right by lately
just have a look at all this stuff in
blue nothing to do with complex numbers
at the moment but but we've been seeing
okay yeah you know when you multiply
topics numbers repeatedly I've you raise
it to a power this is what happens the
argument do you remember now so let's
see first let's just write down tomorrow
sir okay so remember don't Marvel's noon
so this says if you take a complex
number and any complex number can be
written in that I've got two forms which
one is better for tomorrow's there is a
rectangular or polar which one I want
polar form the one with the angle in it
right demaurius nirav says if you've got
any complex number here it is in polar
form if you raise that number to a power
of how you lay right what happens what
happens to the modulus how it also gets
raised to that power that's just that's
just index lost okay and then what
happens to the argument yeah you get a
multiple right in this case it's going
to be n feet up and then I sign and feel
okay so what we're going to do is we're
just going to take the particular case
where your modulus is once we're on the
unit circle because I want to see if I
can get these results if I can
corroborate them and see if I can get
like higher powers in an easier way so
I'm going to consider R equals 1 so that
means i can write this oops sorry I've
prematurely pretty mad
this is what democracy looks like if you
use any complex number that's on the
unit circle it's got modulus one okay so
far so good now what we're considering
is in the bomb adjusted N equals 3 N
equals three and one of the lovely
things about mathematics is that no
matter what problem you've got no matter
which way you approach it if the method
you've chosen is sound you should come
to the same answer at the end this is
one of the ways we know like how do you
know have you ever wondered in our pants
and columns right you're like I don't
know whether my answer is right you look
at the textbook right wait yes I'm okay
just probability in general you do a
probability question and then you look
at the answer and it's like some weird
looking faction you know I okay i guess
the textbook says it's right we'll have
the textbook or thurs motor whether they
were by the answer is they look at the
problem of your run angle they look at
the pump from another angle if they get
the same answer then they're on the
right track